el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador fue claro no permitirá a
Estados Unidos usara sus fuerzas
militares en su país para luchar contra
los carteles nosotros no vamos a
permitir
que intervenga ningún gobierno
extranjero Y mucho menos
que intervengan fuerzas armadas
el miércoles varios republicanos
declararon la guerra a los carteles
mexicanos y anunciaron que en los
próximos días presentarán dos proyectos
de ley para declarar a estas
organizaciones como grupos terroristas
esto permitiría activar más mecanismos
contra ellos como el uso del ejército
unos incluso llamaron a la intervención
del ejército estadounidense en México
para luchar mejor contra los cárteles El
secuestro la semana pasada en la
frontera de cuatro estadounidenses de
los cuales dos murieron llevo los
legisladores republicanos a querer
adoptar una línea más dura contra el
narcotráfico
otro punto de inflexión el auge del
fentanilo en Estados Unidos que se está
produciendo en gran parte en México en
2022 la administración de control de
drogas estadounidense decomisó 379
millones de dosis según el organismo una
cantidad lo suficiente como para matar a
todos los estadounidenses sin embargo
este jueves amlo dijo que no tenía
problemas con esta substancia en su
territorio y que era un asunto de
Estados Unidos y de su sociedad que
calificó de decadente